since its brand has continued to bleed
favorability over the years the GOP is
at times talked a big game about
reaching libertarian voters with ten
candidates crowding the stage and a
handful of others waiting in the wings
have the libertarian outreach go in that
first debate here are the three most and
least libertarian moments of the first
GOP debate the third least libertarian
moments the purpose of the military's
kill people and break things Republicans
like to talk tough on cutting spending
but when it comes to the military money
is no object for many of these
candidates need to have a national
security that puts steel in front of our
enemies you know the sequester is
cutting the heart out of our personnel
we've reduced the military by
twenty-five percent under President
Obama the third most libertarian moment
look I I'm an old-fashioned person here
and I happen to believe in traditional
marriage it seems many Republicans have
all but given up on the gay marriage
fight and that's a win for libertarian
who Court has ruled and I said we'll
accept it and guess what I just went to
a wedding of a friend of mine who
happens to be gay got a one my marriage
all my guns registered in Washington the
second piece of the libertarian moment
I'm not sure how paying for transgender
surgery for soldiers sailors airmen
Marines makes our country safer but
former governor and talk show host Mike
Huckabee can always be relied upon to be
consistently awful it's time that we
recognize the Supreme Court is not the
Supreme Being and we change the policy
to be pro-life and protect children
instead of rip up their body parts and
sell them like they're parts to a Buick
illegals prostitutes pimps drug dealers
all the people that are freeloading off
the system now that's why it ought to be
a transform system the second most
libertarian moment
I want to collect more records from
terrorists but less records from
innocent Americans Governor Chris
Christie was almost enough to make this
moment a low point for libertarians but
Senator Rand Paul salvaged it by
standing up for privacy rights with a
rejection of NSA spying in the defense
of the Fourth Amendment the Fourth
Amendment was what we fought the
revolution over John Adams said it was a
spark that led to our war for
independence and I'm proud of standing
in the bag you know that's a completely
ridiculous answer I want to collect more
records from terrorists but less records
from other people how are you supposed
to know megan is the Fortius muslin how
are you so beautiful on a how you get a
warrant and these libertarian moments of
the GOP debate we need to build a wall
and it has to be built quickly it may
not surprise you that our least
libertarian moment came from Donald
Trump in the midst of a lecture full of
anti-immigration fearmonger but we need
Jeb to build a wall we need to keep
illegals out the most libertarian moment
then again Trump did deliver as only
Trump could one of the nights truest
statements one which any libertarian
would be hard-pressed to argue with jar
leaders are stupid our politicians are
stupid